[Music]
if you want to fly a plane into a
hostile environment whether that's enemy
territory or a raging hurricane there
aren't many better crafts than an
unmanned aerial vehicle like the Global
Hawk what's neat about these airplanes
is that you can get in a very high
altitude you can do that with Mandor
planes too but uniquely you can get this
over a weather system for a very long
period of time you observe a hurricane
as it develops and then runs through its
whole cycle for you know up to almost a
day to do missions like that the Global
Hawk climbs to 60,000 feet on its
massive wings Frank and I took a walk
around one do you know if the top of you
had how many feet this is yeah we've got
about 116 feet from tip to tip and it's
a high aspect ratio when you're trying
to get a bunch of a wing area out there
airplane flies very high up around 6,000
on the end back up to the front yeah so
there's very little so it needs this
much swinging for the lift that's right
that's right you're trying to support
you know Oh in the mid 20 thousand pound
range of weight up at altitude and then
again you have this one opened up for us
which is fantastic because I've never
seen the engine in these either so it's
a full sized jet engine at the back of a
single jet engine a big turbofan made by
rolls-royce so is this the type of thing
we would see on a you know a
conventional a liner it looks like the
sort of thing you'd see hung underneath
the wing this engine you might even see
on a small corporate jet nASA has been
repurposing military global hopes since
2010 it uses them to study and to
monitor extreme weather like hurricanes
so yea this other airframe over here
we're in the process of decommissioning
it did a long hard series of flights for
us so it was fine getting kind of worn
out early one very first Global Hawk
ever produced it's my very first one
yeah and so we turned it into a science
bird when Department of Defense was done
using it as a test bird
Global Hawks can be programmed to fly
completely autonomously but NASA of
course keeps a close eye on the planes
from a control room the data they
collect is critical to accurate weather
forecasts yeah every looks at the
weather a day they go their websites all
those website information is based on
modeling forecasting what's going to be
happening anywhere from the next few
hours is next few days so the
instruments on these type of aircraft
collect data that's used enhance those
models and try to make them more correct
over time so the next time you check
your favorite weather app the accuracy
of that forecast might be because nASA
has one of these flying robots aloft
[Music]